The right answer is four times. And I
sort of walked through that for you hopefully
you got that. Basically, the kernel has to
copy from the client address space into the kernel
buffer. That's the first copy. The second copy
is, the kernel has to copy from the kernel
buffer into the server. And then the third
time when the procedure is completed, the server procedure
is completed, the kernel has to copy it from the server address
using the kernel, and then the fourth time, it's going to be copied from
the kernel buffer into the client. So it's tough being moved from
the user address space... Through the kernel and back out happens four times.